if Chrome is so good why do people still
use Firefox well there's actually
several legitimate reasons for this
starting with the computational
requirements it may not seem like it but
Chrome is actually rather
computationally intense and thus is not
very helpful for devices with lower
specs moving on from performance related
benefits we have privacy benefits it's
no secret that Google makes most of
their money by collecting your data and
serving relevant ads Firefox on the
other hand is a non-profit and doesn't
track your browsing history by default
Firefox also blocks cookies and they
generally have substantially better
privacy features than Google given that
they don't have anything to gain from
making these policies loose now it
should be noted that Firefox does not
wipe out data collection altogether if
you go to google.com on Firefox Google
can still collect a bunch of data but if
you use Firefox in combination with
something like duckduckgoa then you'll
actually have a chance at protecting
your privacy